it's a new week and that means it's time
for new releases mariya swamped this
week so it looks like you're stuck with
me if you manage to snag an early
pre-order of the oculus rift and you'll
finally be able to step into the future
of gaming the Valkyrie and Lucky's tale
will come packaged with the headset but
if the headset didn't break the bank
here's some other games you can pick up
for your new toy adrift adventure time
magic man's head games blaze rush
Chronos dead secret Eve gun jack flight
Akuma keep talking and nobody explodes
radio G smashing the battle and winland
the oculus rift and all these games will
come out on March 28 those of us who are
either too broke or don't have a strong
enough allegiance to the pc masterrace
there's still plenty of games coming out
this week first MLB the show swings its
way on the playstation 4 playstation 3
this week this year adds Showtime mode
which lets you slow down time and
interact with plays that might normally
seem mundane and improved road to the
show mode that offers a far more
personalized experience and a conquest
mode where you travel across North
America earning fans and holding
territories with the power of America's
favorite pastime you can step up to bat
on March 29 but if you don't own a
Playstation and you still want to take a
visit to a virtual ballpark you're in
luck because RBI Baseball 2016 comes out
March 29 while you're waiting for
Resident Evil 4 to re-release on
current-gen consoles you can replay the
not-so-great resident evil 6 I hope
you're not sick of killing zombies and
grotesque monsters as Leon Kennedy Chris
Redfield and jake muller you know the
guy with his head shave that no one
really cares about the game features
three different interconnected campaigns
all of which can be played cooperatively
and you can get that on the 29th if
adventure games are more your thing you
can pick up episode 5 of minecraft story
mode and episode 2 of the walking dead
michonne episode 5 is called order up
and it will bridge the gap between the
first season and the next three episodes
which were recently announced give me no
shelter the second of three episodes for
the walking dead michonne will launch
the same day you can download both of
these
the twenty-ninth killer instinct also
kicks off season 3 on the 29 eight new
and returning fighters will be released
over the course of the next few months
including everyone's favorite battle
toad in the arbiter from Halo rash the
arbiter Kim woo and tusk will be
available right off the bat there are
three different versions of season 3
that you might want to know about a
twenty-dollar combo breaker edition a
forty dollar ultra edition and the sixty
dollars supreme edition but just to be
clear all three of these versions
include access to all eight characters
once they launch finally the game I'm
most excited for this week is hyper
light drifter the game will release on
March 31st for windows and mac and
unfortunately you're gonna have to wait
a little bit longer for it to come to
consoles hyper light drifter is a
colorful dream like top-down RPG in the
vein of classic 16-bit games you play as
a drifter a collector of Forgotten
knowledge searching for a cure to a
vicious disease and that's just about it
for this week let me know which game
you're looking forward to and remember
these dates are based on publisher
listings and are subject to change
you